>> Tucker: NEWLY RELEASED
RADIO REPORTINGS FROM THE
PARKLAND MASSACRE APPEAR TO
SHOW MORE FAILURES BY
BROWARD COUNTY POLICE AS
THEY RESPONDED TO THE
ATTACK.
FOX CORRESPONDENT MATT FINN
HAS BEEN BREAKING NEWS ON
THIS STORY FOR DAYS NOW.
HE JOINS US WITH WHAT HE HAS
GOT.
HEY, MATT.
>> TUCKER, WE KNOW ABOUT
EVERY OFFICER THAT RESPONDED
TO THE PARKLAND FLORIDA
SHOOTING WAS POTENTIALLY
RISKING THEIR LIVES THERE
EMERGING FROM THAT DAY.
HOWEVER, NEWLY RELEASED
DISPATCH RECORDINGS SEEM TO
CONFIRM WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING RIGHT HERE ON THIS
SHOW AND THAT THAT THE
COMMANDING OFFICER AND.
SO FIRST RESPONDERS FOCUSED
ON BLOCKING TRAFFIC AND
SETTING UP A PERIMETER
INSTEAD OF RUSHING IN TO
KILL THE SHOOTER, WHICH IS
WHAT THEY ARE TRAINED TO DO.
ONE RANKING OFFICER TELLS
FOX NEWS TONIGHT THAT THE
RESPONDERS THAT DAY SHOULD
HAVE SAID YOU TAKE THE FIRST
FLOOR.
I'LL TAKE THE SECOND.
YOU TAKE THE THIRD AND WE
WON'T STOP UNTIL WE KILL THE
SHOOTER.
IN A PORTION OF THE AUDIO
YOU ARE ABOUT TO HEAR, A
MALE VOICE BELIEVE TO BE THE
DISGRACED SCHOOL OFFICER
IDENTIFIES WHAT SCHOOL
BUILDING HE THINKS THE SHOTS
ARE COMING FROM AND THEN
COMMANDS OFFICERS TO STAY
AWAY FROM THAT BUILDING.
NOTEWORTHY THAT THIS GOES
AGAINST HIS INITIAL
STATEMENT THAT HE DIDN'T GO
IN THE SCHOOL BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T KNOW WHERE THE SHOTS
WERE COMING FROM.
YOU ARE ALSO GOING TO HEAR A
FEMALE VOICE OF THE
COMMANDING OFFICER.
HER TWO AUDIBLE COMMANDS
ABOUT A PERIMETER NOT
KILLING THE SHOOTER.
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE HAD
DEFENDED ITSELF.
EXPLAINING THAT THE ALLEGED
BAD COMMAND HAPPENED AFTER
THE SHOOTING STOPPED FIRING.
AS YOU ARE ABOUT TO HEAR IT
DID SEEMS THE OFFICERS DID
NOT KNOW FOR THE SHOOTER WAS
AFTER THE TIME AFTER
OFFICERS PRIORITIZED THE
TRAFFIC ONE OFFICER SAYING
THERE MIGHT BE MORE BULLETS
COMING FROM A WINDOW.
HERE IS.
SO AUDIO RECORDINGS.
♪
>> ONE RANKING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT
JUST LISTENED TO THE AUDIO
WE DID SENT IS A RESPONSE TO
FOX NEWS WRITING IN PART,
WOW:  I JUST LISTENED TO THE
FIRST 10 MINUTES OF THE
DISPATCH TAPES.
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO
LISTEN TO.
WE FAILED IN MANY WAYS.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'LL BE ABLE
TO SLEEP TONIGHT.
ALSO HERE IS ONE PARENT WHO
TONIGHT TELLS FOX NEWS THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF PARKLAND
PARENTS ARE IRATE.
>> LIVES ARE BEING LOST
WHILE THE DEPUTIES WHO ARE
ON SIGHT WERE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT CLOSING OFF ROADWAYS
THAN THEY WERE ABOUT GOING
INTO THE BUILDING AND
STOPPING THE SHOOTER AND
SAVING LIVES.
>> TODAY FLORIDA'S
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR RICK
SCOTT APPROVED NEW
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
REQUIRE ANYONE PURCHASING A
GUN IN THE STATE TO BE 21
YEARS OLD AND THE NRA
IMMEDIATELY FILED A LAWSUIT.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: THANKS, MATT.
APPRECIATE IT.
JEFF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BROWARD COUNTY POLICE
BENEVOLENCE ASSOCIATION.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
JEFF, THANKS A LOT FOR
COMING ON.
YOU HEARD MATT FINN READ THE
EMAIL HE RECEIVED FROM AN
OFFICER.
YOU PROBABLY KNOW THE
PERSON, SAYING HE WAS IN
EFFECT HEART BROKEN TO HEAR
THAT TAPE.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO IT
IT?
>> I LISTENED TO THE TAPES
AND ALSO IN RECEIPT OF OF A
CHRONOLOGY OF EVENTS THAT
CAME OUT FROM THE BROWARD'S
SHERIFF'S OFFICE WITH FOUR
DIFFERENT SOURCES.
THE VIDEO CRAWL SPRINGS
FIRES AND CORAL SPRINGS
POLICE AND DISPATCH.
>> HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
PEOPLE, AUTHORITIES WITH
FIREARMS ON THE SCENE NEVER
ENTERED THE BUILDING WHILE
PEOPLE WERE BEING MURDERED.
DO YOU?
>> NO.
I CAN'T EXPLAIN THAT.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU GUESS AS
TO WHAT MIGHT HAVE HAPPENED?
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS BEFORE?
>> NO, I HAVEN'T.
AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE ONE VIDEO HAS THE
SCHOOL RESOURCE DEPUTY AT
THE ADMINISTRATION BUILDING
THEN HEADING TOWARDS
BUILDING 12 AND THEN TAKING
UP A POSITION OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING 12.
THAT'S ON THE CHRONOLOGY OF
EVENTS.
THAT'S ALSO ON THE VIDEO.
>> Tucker: BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
AT LEAST SOME OF THESE GUYS
KNEW THAT THERE WAS SHOOTING
INSIDE THE BUILDING.
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T WANT
TO IMPUGN PEOPLE'S MOTIVES,
BUT OTHER THAN COWARD DIS.
WHAT WOULD BE THE
EXPLANATION FOR THAT?
>> I DON'T HAVE AN
EXPLANATION FOR THAT PERSON
NOT GOING IN I CAN TELL YOU
CORAL SPRINGS POLICE
DEPARTMENT ALL THE 911 CALLS
WERE GOING TO CORAL SPRINGS
FIRE.
IF YOU ARE IN THE CITY OF
PARKLAND AND DIAL 911.
IT GOES TO CORAL SPRINGS
FIRE DISPATCH BECAUSE THEY
PROVIDE FIRE SERVICES AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR THE
CITY OF PARKLAND.
SO, ALL THE LIVE INTEL WAS
GOING TO THE CORAL SPRINGS
POLICE OFFICERS.
AND THE CHRONOLOGY THAT I
HAVE CORAL SPRINGS AND
BROWARD OFFICERS
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENTERED THE
STRUCTURE AND STARTED TO
CLEAR IT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK IT'S
A
LITTLE WEIRD THAT THE
SHERIFF OF BROWARD COUNTY
THAT DEPARTMENT FAILED I
NEED TO SURRENDER MY GUN
RIGHTS THAT'S THE LESSON?
>> I'M SORRY.
SAY THAT AGAIN.
I'M SORRY.
>> Tucker: WHY ISN'T THE
SHERIFF OF BROWARD COUNTY
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THIS?
>> I CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
I WOULD SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
THE BUCK STOPS AT THE TOP.
BUT I CAN'T ANSWER FOR THE
SHERIFF.
>> Tucker: I HOPE HE IS.